[Music]
from Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
our next guest has been known to pop up
from underground locations himself
that's because his passion is exploring
the subterranean world from sewers to
subway tunnels to abandoned mine shafts
he's detailed his adventure in his debut
non-fiction book underground the human
history of the worlds beneath our feet
and author wilhunt joins us now
above-ground will good morning Julie
good morning thanks so much
so this started when you were a kid a
teenager really what made you want to go
underground and explore so when I was 16
years old I discovered an abandoned
railroad tunnel that ran almost directly
beneath my house in Provence Rhode
Island and it it just kind of opened a
bolt in my imagination because it was
this sort of big spooky mysterious
unfamiliar place beneath the most
familiar territory you can imagine and I
kind of got to thinking that that there
are spaces like this beneath every
territory in the world you can go
anywhere and look beneath your feet and
there's something wondrous and marvelous
beneath from that moment every manhole
cover was an opportunity exactly you've
been all of it you've been doing this
all over the world in Paris for example
you describe what's underneath Paris as
like a mystery novel so beneath the
streets of Paris there are 200 miles of
limestone quarries known as the
catacombs and there's just it's just
this sprawling earthy honeycomb and you
can go down there with the people who
kind of patrol the area there the catta
files and they go down and have parties
and they mix sculptures and they paint
it is own world these are like the mole
people of the
old I guess they're they live above
ground but they club house but you have
found people in New York for example who
live below ground literally mopey yes
there are there people living beneath
the streets of New York known as the
mole people who have sort of made
dwellings in the hidden nooks of the
city you found one woman who's lived
down there for 28 years yes there's a
tunnel running under the Upper West Side
known as the freedom tunnel and in an
alcove of that tunnel a woman named
Brooklyn has been living for 28 years
this isn't exactly legal is it it is not
always legal that's correct so that's
gotta be tough too you got a super
Sneaky about this yeah thing in some
cases you have to be a little bit sneaky
when I'm running subway tunnels under
New York City that's you know the NYPD
at PD does not like that so be careful
in doing all of this and I look back at
why you started doing this have you
discovered something more about our
world by seeing the world beneath our
feet of course I think that that you
know humans have been interacting in
visceral ways with subterranean places
for hundreds of thousands of years so
when you are peering into a tunnel or
into the mouth of a cave you're engaging
with a really deep primal human
tradition anywhere where you haven't
been able to go beneath yet but you'd
like to there are some caves in Oaxaca
in Mexico that I have been dreaming
about and I haven't been able to get in
there what is in your dream we played a
clip from Indiana Jones - coming into
this you've actually had an experience
like that where you were you popped up
in an unexpected place so this is in
Paris with a group of urban explorers we
walked from one edge of Paris to the
other edge from south to north
using only underground infrastructure
and at the end of two days we emerged
through a manhole cover in the sidewalk
at the foot of a restaurant on six of us
coming out just spattered in mud and
other other substances
to surprise a number of diners no in
reading your book though there are
several places though that you point out
for ecological and for you know for just
for the people of those spaces in
Western Australia in Mexico and others
you know this these places are sacred
there are some of them are extremely
powerful sacred places I've visited a
sacred mine in Western Australia that's
the oldest mine in the world it's 35
thousand years old
it's an ochre mine and ochre is the red
clay like material that's very sacred to
average Aboriginal people they believe
it's the the blood of their ancestors
and I was able to enter this mine and
climb down to the bottom just sort of
engulfed in this red soft material and
you've had a spiritual moment in in some
ways yes in a cave in in this in the
southwest of France and the Pyrenees I
was able to visit a private cave that's
owned by an old family who's lived there
for generations and they don't let
people down they open it once a year at
the most and they let me do the very
back of the cave a half mile underground
and there was a pair of sculptures clay
sculptures of bison look at him there
yeah 15 thousand years old and I in the
moment of Revelation there I sort of
cleared up and it was just very powerful
well we'd love to hear more I just know
there's one place you haven't been and
that's the CBS catacomb